nous sommes le jeudi à 6 avril nous
sommes à lui et faire des sciences ici à
l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à mes côtés le
professeur Eric azabou qui a organisé
une journée un peu spéciale ici à
l'occasion de la Semaine Olympique sur
le thème de l'inclusion tout à fait ici
à l'université tout un après-midi dédié
au judo dans une modalité inclusive
c'est à dire Andy judo en partenariat
avec la commission Andy judo de du
comité 78 l'objectif étant de démontrer
fait des démonstrations de comment se
passe en deux judo et montrer aussi que
c'est possible que toute personne même
en situation de handicap peut pratiquer
le judo et en profiter pour son
bien-être mais également il y a quelques
champignons du lundi judo sachant que le
handy judo reste avec le taekwondo les
deux seuls disciplines des arts martiaux
à être représentés aux Jeux
paralympiques depuis le judo Jeux
paralympiques depuis 1988 mais c'est
très peu connu d'où l'occasion de
profiter de cette semaine olympique dans
le thème à l'inclusion pour mettre en
lumière cette activité là qui est autant
important pour les personnes en
situation de handicap mais aussi
simplement le judo pour toute personne
est vraiment source de d'émancipation
d'équilibre et c'est beaucoup de valeur
ça va tomber ça va se relever et puis
pour dire simplement aussi que le judo
reste la discipline qui rapporte à la
France le plus de médailles actuellement
quand même
lors de ces Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques alors on le voit derrière
nous il y a des exercices qui sont
proposés par les professeurs de cette
journée qu'est-ce qu'ils vont apprendre
pendant cette journée voilà pendant
cette journée il s'agit vraiment pour
les professeurs de démontrer aux
personnes parfois en situation de
handicap qui pratique déjà le judo
depuis ce moment démontrer de nouvelles
techniques pour être encore plus au
point
montrer comment le judo a permis de se
structurer davantage dans la société
merci professeur Eric azzabou et nous
allons maintenant rencontrer un judoka
qui donne des cours cet après-midi
et voilà nous sommes donc maintenant
avec le judoka Benjamin Axus alors
Benjamin qu'est-ce que ça vous apporte
vous de faire ce type d'activité
alors tout d'abord à la base on le fait
pas pour nous on le fait principalement
pour les autres parce qu'on le fait avec
des personnes en situation de handicap
alors après effectivement c'est des
choses qui nous apportent quand même
quand même à nous moi en tant que
personne en tant que sportif c'est vrai
que ça m'apporte pas mal de choses je me
rends compte à quel point les ils sont
courageux et en fait ils mettent une
tellement de positivité dans leur dans
leur sport et dans la pratique du judo
que vraiment ça nous ça nous donne le
sourire et ça nous fait relativiser sur
plein de choses vous leur apprenez les
petites techniques je n'hésitez pas
ouais on essaie de leur apprendre que ça
soit apprendre à chuter ce qui est
important parce que la vie de tous les
jours on est amené par voie
malheureusement à chuter donc ils
apprennent à savoir chuter pour pas se
faire trop mal ou après on a on les a
pris aussi à faire chuter leur
adversaire dans le vraiment dans les
dans le thème du judo donc c'est bien ça
les ça les sort un peu de leur quotidien
et on leur apprend on leur apprend à
sport qui est vraiment avec des valeurs
importantes et je pense que aujourd'hui
ça montre qu'on est là pour eux et que
eux ils sont vraiment contents d'être là
ils viennent là vraiment pour apprendre
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
voit que au judo tout le monde peut
participer peu importe son handicap peu
importe les problèmes qui peut avoir
tout le monde peut pratiquer le judo et
c'est ça qui est qui est génial et c'est
moi c'est ce qui m'a vraiment le plus
choqué moi c'est que je m'attendais pas
à soi aussi inclusive que ça et vraiment
tout le monde peut participer tout le
monde peut faire du judo aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment ça qu'on essaie de
montrer vous leur parler un petit peu
des Jeux olympiques de 2024 j'imagine
bah ouais ils savent tous que voilà moi
c'est de la compétition du coup ils sont
à fond derrière moi et m'envoie plein
d'autres positifs donc dès que dès une
petite médaille je la ramènerai ici avec
plaisir alors vous êtes yvelinois vous
êtes originaire de Montfort-l'Amaury
est-ce que c'est une saveur particulière
d'être ici dans les Yvelines à
Versailles pour vous bah bien sûr ça
fait toujours plaisir de revenir de
revenir près de chez soi
j'ai passé une grande partie de mon
temps quand j'étais jeune donc non ça me
fait très plaisir de venir ici et de le
faire à Versailles donc c'est un plaisir
pour moi de d'être dans les Yvelines ça
compte pour moi en tout cas
cette journée sur l'inclusion se termine
ici à l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines d'autres
opérations de ce type se dérouleront sur
site dans les prochains mois